c'est un classique de la vie des élus
revisitait cette année par le maire de
Chartres un hommage aux 8 mai 1945
version intelligence artificielle le
résultat un texte cohérent le jour J et
le nom donné au débarquement des forces
alliés en Normandie mais pas franchement
poignant de cet anniversaire est
également important pour rappeler
l'importance de l'appel en le monde
Seigneur il est 8h30
voilà Gauthier Le Bret qui est tombé en
arrivant sur le plateau il se relève
tout va bien visiblement tout va bien
j'ai eu peur mais ça va
on se dit tout ça se passe derrière la
caméra mais j'ai une certaine frayeur
allez entrer Gauthier et Georges Fenech
est avec est avec nous également voilà
c'est le direct le maire empêchait
d'écrire à cause d'un bras cassé à lui
trouver chat GPT parfait pour sa 22e
cérémonie du 8 mai moi j'utilise un peu
tchatche j'ai pété je dis c'est
l'occasion et j'ai vu quelque chose de
satisfaisant la démo qui reviennent trop
souvent et j'ai voulu le laisser
suffisamment brut pour montrer que
c'était une fabrication qui n'était pas
humaine alors j'espère que vous n'aurez
jamais allé aux urgences à Lyon ou les
infirmières sont plutôt occupés à danser
sur Tik Tok qu'à soigner les patients
[Musique]
alors on nous passons tous un temps
infini sur nos écrans il est urgent de
réguler internet en conseil des
ministres ce matin un texte de
transcription de la nouvelle
réglementation européenne sur le
numérique était présenté quelques
mesures phares bannir les
cyber-harceleurs bloquer les sites
pornographiques pour les mineurs mais
aussi les médias de propagande et puis
installé un filtre anti-arnaque
personnellement j'ai gagné aucune
animation aujourd'hui et je suis
vraiment dégoûtée
ça parce que vous ne connaissez pas
encore le gage qui vous attend un bisou
de tourtereaux oui allez c'est bon qu'on
est en direct de Pointe-à-Pitre
bonjour
monsieur pas vrai quel plaisir
j'ai envie de vous demander quel temps
fait-il mais vu votre bronzage et votre
coupe de cheveux je suis un peu énervé
madame alors la nuit vous êtes en
Bretagne aujourd'hui pourquoi à
Saint-Seine-l'Abbaye exactement on va
Côte d'Or
Bretagne
donc on va pas cueillir les escargots
aujourd'hui avec vous les amis vous
allez nous parler de la vie est parfait
donc on va parler de l'Aïd des ours sous
la pluie c'est pas facile on pauvre Loïs
allez-y sortez madame là on est en
direct de Pointe-à-Pitre non non
[Applaudissements]
au revoir madame le succès la chanteuse
américaine Taylor Swift le connaît déjà
en témoigne les milliers de personnes
venues voir son concert à Nashville aux
États-Unis mais la pluie s'est également
invitée des précipitations importantes
qui n'ont pourtant pas empêché l'artiste
de continuer son show
[Musique]
quoi de mieux qu'une averse pour
terminer en beauté sur son titre
midnight rain comprenez plus de minuit
[Applaudissements]
qui avait perdu hein
on a pris un peu de retard sur d'autres
enquêtes cette affaire de drogue pendant
vert islamisme Molenbeek où les tueries
du Brabant mais on a retrouvé le type
qui avait perdu son billet de 50 ans on
peut pas être sur tous les dossiers non
plus chapeau à la police belge qui
veille tandis que les Français affirment
être de plus en plus économe et que 83%
d'entre eux associent l'argent au
plaisir les personnes interrogées ont
aussi répondu à une affirmation qui fait
souvent débat l'argent ne fait pas le
bonheur et selon le sondage de l’époque
62% des Français seraient d'accord avec
cette fameuse expression une donnée
contestée par d'autres personnes ça
c'est vraiment un discours de riche
péruvienne excusez-moi mais là ils sont
sur le dos parce qu'il y a des gens qui
ont dérobé pour 12000 euros de basket
mais seulement des pieds droits alors
évidemment dans cette affaire quelque
chose
ah oui à mon avis c'est ça c'est le gang
des cul-de-jatte
qui doit être recherché le problème le
taillage le taillage du champignon il
est beaucoup plus chunky comme ça tac
tac
ça veut dire un peu freestyle un peu tu
vois
non ça veut pas dire ça veut pas dire un
peu
freestyle non ça veut dire pas un peu
toute live
[Musique]
c'est un concept aussi ça on a un gros
il y a de l'alimentaire ici d'accord ok
[Musique]
je suis
rassuré je vois une galette avec un
oumoude Dina on vous a déjà prévenu hier
qu'on dit du houmous amis
[Musique]
je suis rassuré pas d'insectes pour moi
ce soir c'est nickel c'est parfait je
comprends je comprends tout à fait
pourquoi il y a autant de moucherons
incroyable
en appartement comme ça dans cet état là
clairement ça fait disjoncter un cleaner
les plombs ils sautent vous goûtez chef
on y aller je vais goûter parce que tu
insistes vraiment il y a pas de problème
ça ICA mais vraiment pas confiance en
moi
[Musique]
je suis cramé là j'ai cramé le palais
cramer là
allez c'est parti joue moi mamie
pardon
ok
je suis désolé
pardon je suis désolé Harman solding
prenait la pose en souriant dans une
tranchée c'était il y a quelques
semaines il aimait dire qu'avec sa
caméra il racontait des histoires il
était passionné par l'information et à
multiplier les reportages depuis le
début de cette guerre en Ukraine hier
après-midi le jeune homme de 32 ans a
trouvé la mort sous une pluie de
roquette près de barmouth Harman est
mort pour nous informer le choc et la
tristesse de ce décès à même dépassé nos
frontières il a consacré sa vie à rendre
compte de la vérité au monde écrit le
ministère ukrainien de la Défense le
monde a une dette envers Arman estime la
porte-parole de la Maison Blanche